[Music]
in the fall of 2008 the economy careened
into unknown territory
41% told Gallup posters the events then
made me feel personally afraid many felt
the financial system would collapse over
the next several years workers anxieties
about their jobs rose in Gallup stated
between 2008 and 2009 the number of
Americans who feared losing their job or
having their pay cut doubled confidence
in banks and financial institutions
plummeted Americans blame banks and Wall
Street for greed they also blamed
regulators for a lack of financial
regulation which they believe
contributed to the crisis what is
changed in the last decade Americans
confidence about their jobs and wages
has returned to pre-crash levels and
they feel very positive about the job
market now confidence in banks and Wall
Street has inched up but only a small
number of Americans believe our
financial system is more secure than it
was then around 1/3 gave that response
to pew in 2013 and 2015 while around 60%
said it was not how do you remember the
financial crisis let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI